字幕: Mai Iida
校正: Arisa Kg
これは昨日の河北新報の朝刊1面です
ここに 今年 米の値段が暴落して
米農家さんが大変困ってるという
ニュースが書いてます
具体的には 秋田県産のひとめぼれが
今年 8400円 去年に比べて2800円下がったと
そして農家が泣いているというニュースです
皆さんはこのニュースに触れたとき
一体何を感じるでしょうか
おそらく「いやぁ 米農家も困ってるんだな
大変なんだな」と 同情すると思います
だけれども この新聞を読み終えた途端に
皆さんの頭の中からこのニュースは
消えてしまうんじゃないでしょうか
私たちが毎日食べているお米
これを作っている生産者が困ってるんですから
決して他人事ではいられないはずです
だけれども どうしてこうも
他人事になってしまうのでしょうか
それは 困っている農家の具体的な顔が
思い浮かばないからだと思います
もしも その顔が思い浮かぶという
農家が知り合いにいたら
決して他人事ではいられないんではないでしょうか
その相手との関係性が共感力を育むんです
消費者と生産者が大きな流通システムで
分断されてしまったこの国で
私たち消費者が得られる食べ物の情報は
値段 見た目 食味 カロリー等
すべて消費領域の話です
もちろん食べ物を選ぶ上で
これらの情報も大事な訳ですけれども
決定的に欠けている情報があります
それが 食べ物の裏側にいる
血の通った人間の存在です
皆さんは日頃 食べている食べ物の中で
「生産者の顔知ってるよ」 何人知っていますか？
おそらく一人も知らないという方が
大半ではないでしょうか
共感力を失ってしまった日本の一次産業は今
深刻な状況になっています
私が生まれるちょっと前の1970年に
1025万人も農家はいたんです
それが今 260万人に激減しました
そのうち実に75%が60歳以上の高齢者です
そして私と同じ40歳以下の若い農家さんは
たったの17万人しかいません
漁師に至っては 同じ1970年に
57万人いました
それが今や17万人
そして過半数が60歳以上の高齢者で
40歳以下はたったの2万人です
10年後 20年後
私たちの食べ物を誰が作っているのでしょうか
おそらく今 私のこの問いかけに対して皆さんは
「いやぁ一次産業なんとかしなきゃいけない」
という気持ちになっていると思います
だけれども やはりこの会場を出た途端に
皆さんの気持ちはどこかに消えてしまうでしょう
私たち消費者に決定的に欠けているのは
私たちの命に直結する一次産業の問題を
自分ごと化する 共感力なんです
そしてこの日本の一次産業を立て直していく為に
食べ物の裏側にいる人間の存在を知り
そしてそことつながっていくことで
共感力を磨いていくことが大事だと思います
そこで私が考えついたのが
食べ物付きの月刊誌 「東北食べる通信」です
毎月東北の生産者にクローズアップして特集し
そこにその生産者が育てた食べ物を
こうして付けて読者に送ります
普通の食の宅配サービスは
段ボールに野菜がいっぱいぎっしり詰まって
そこに生産者情報の紙切れ1枚が入っていますが
我々はそれをひっくり返したんです
この紙切れ1枚こそが この生産者の生き様こそが
メインの商品だよと
そしてそこにあえて付録として
こうして食べ物を付けました
一年間やってきて今 読者が1400人になっています
読者は 届いた雑誌 16ページありますけれども
まず生産者のことを知る
その上で調理をして食べる
ここで終わりません
我々は特集した生産者と読者を
Facebookのグループでつなげてみました
そうしたところ
実に活発なコミュニケーションが起きたんです
だって初めて知った訳です
自分が口の中に入れる食べ物を作っている人
そうして多くの読者の方々が
「こんな風に息子と調理して食べました」
というレシピの写真の投稿と共に
生産者に対して感謝の言葉を
「いただきます」「ありがとうございます」
「感動しました」「ごちそうさまでした」
連日 食べ物の感謝の気持ちを生産者に伝えました
そして生産者も これまでは流通に出して終わりです
しかし食べて喜んでくれる人の声に連日触れて
「よし もっとうまいもの作ってやろう」と
こういう生産意欲を増しています
さらに
[オンラインの］ SNSのこういう交流だけではなくて
実際に生産者さんを東京に呼んで交流会を開いたり
あるいは読者が生産現場を訪ねて
実際に体を動かして出荷を体験する
こういうリアルの体験イベントも行っています
これらの一連の体験をパッケージとして
毎月読者の皆様にお届けしているわけですが
こうした一連の体験を通じて
読者は共感力を増していきました
その共感力を遺憾なく発揮した事例が最近ありました
昨年10月号で特集した 秋田県 潟上市の米農家
菊地晃生さんです
彼は ここは現場なんですけれども
耕さない冬水田んぼという農法で
人間と自然にとても優しい米を作っています
ところが 今年雨が長引いて
稲刈りの時期になっても 田んぼがぬかるんだ状態で
稲刈り機のコンバインを入れても
前に進まないという状況になったんです
小さな娘さん二人 そして妻と四人で手刈りをしても
例年の10分の1も刈り取れないということで
絶望の縁に立たされました
彼はそこで 自分の窮状について
Facebookで発信して
食べる通信の読者グループにSOSを出したんですね
そしたらば なんと200人に及ぶ読者を始めとする
晃生さんの仲間たちが 秋田までわざわざ行って
裸足になって 田んぼに入って
そして一緒に手で刈って
およそ野球場一つになるぐらいの広大な
1ヘクタールのこの田んぼが
まもなく人力によって刈り取られようとしています
つまり読者と生産者が
心配し合う家族みたいになっているわけですよ
読者はこうして食べ物の裏側にいる
人間の存在を知ることで
まさにこの米農家に降り掛かった災難を
自分ごと化して
そして自ら突き動かして生産現場に訪れていきました
私は今 地縁血縁がどんどん
希薄になっていく世の中になって
食べる人と作る人がつながることで
豊かにできるコミュニティに可能性を見出しています
一年間を通じて私たちは
こういうコミュニティをつくりました
この中には漁師もいれば農家もいます 前の方にいます
後ろの方は読者です
見てくださいこの笑顔
笑顔になっているのは生産者だけではなくて
食べる方 読者の方も
実はどんどん どんどん喜びに満ちていきます
今回の秋田の米農家さんのところに
手伝いに行った読者も
元気になって都会に帰っていくんですよ
自分の命を支えている食べ物が
どういう自然環境に育まれ
そこに生産者がどういう手間を加えて
作っているのかを 肌で感じることで
読者は 命が喜ぶと言います
私は一年間 この食べる人と作る人をつなげる
「食べる通信」という仕事をしてみて
気付きました
生産者と消費者が分断され
困っていたのは 実は生産者だけではなかった
この消費者の命が喜ばず
元気を失っていたということに気付きました
そしてこの両者の間にある垣根を取り払っていくことで
両者が交わっていくことで
お互いの元気 そして生きる力を
交換できるんだということを
僕は彼らに教わったんです
今 私たちは 完成された消費社会を生きています
このスマートフォン一台あれば
マンションの一室にこもって
何でも買えてしまう
生きていける
だけれども そこには波乱の困難もありません
食べ物を育む自然だったり
そこに手間を加えた食べ物を作っている生産者は
視界の外に消えてしまいます
そうして予測やコントロールや秩序や正義が成された
完璧なまでの消費社会の中で
私たちは生きる喜びや 生きる実感を
気付かぬうちに
失いかけて来たんではないんでしょうか
私は そういう狭い世界をひっくり返したいと思いました
この構築された消費社会に
風穴を開けたいと思いました
その方法を私は「食べる通信」を通じて知ったんです
その方法を 今日は皆さんに教えようと思います
何も地方に移住して生産者になる必要はないです
都市に暮らしながらにしてできることです
それは これまでの交換可能な
お金と食べ物という貧しい関係から抜け出して
本来の交換不可能な 食べる人と作る人という
豊かな関係に戻すことで
皆さんにとって 食べるということは
他者との関係性や まだ見ぬ広い世界とつながる
回路として再生していくことができるんです
そしてこの回路を通じて
この小さな小さな 小さいかもしれないけれども
この回路を通じて 構築された消費社会に
隙間 創造的なスペースを作り出し
そしてそこから私たちは
生きる力や 生きる喜びや 生きる実感や
そして想像力を取り戻していく
狭い世界に閉じ込められた私たち人間が持っていた
本来の可能性や精神性を
未来へと解き放っていくんです
その先にこそ 私たちの命が喜ぶ
新しいフロンティアが待っていると思います
私たちが暮らすこの日本で
私たちは今
命が喜ばない 命の居心地がとても悪くなっています
何でこんなことになってしまったのでしょうか
私は思います
頭と体のバランスが崩れ
我々は皆
頭でっかちになってしまったのではないでしょうか
消費社会というのは 私たちの頭が考え出し
作り出したものです
それに対して 私たちがいくら考えても
作り出せないものがあります
それが自然です
私たちは元々自然から発生してきたので
自然の中に身を置くと 誰もが心地いいと感じるでしょう
その自然を消費社会は徹底的に排除していきました
そして我々のこの体自体も
人間が作り出せないという意味で
本来は自然のものです
ですから 気持ちがいいとか 美しいとか
感動したとか
こういう感情というのは
頭ではなくて体で感じるものです
この身体性や精神性
こういうものも 感情も 消費社会は時に
私たちから奪い去ってしまうことになります
同じことが 日本にも言えると思うんです
人間は頭と体の釣り合いが取れるところが
必ずあるはずです
ここの均衡が崩れると 人は
命の心地が悪くなります
日本も今 頭と体の関係と 都市と地方の関係
僕は似てると思うんです
東京一極集中が加速し
そして全国の農山漁村が消滅の危機にあります
かつて長男が戦後 全国の農山漁村に残って
次男以下の兄弟が出稼ぎでつくった街が
今の東京 大阪 名古屋です
つまり都市と地方は血でつながっていたんです
ですからみんな 盆暮れに帰省ラッシュするのでしょう
ところがあと20年30年経つと
この帰省ラッシュが無くなると言われています
つまり
都市生まれの 都市育ちの ふるさとがない人間が
たくさん量産されるということです
こうなると 都市と地方の分断は決定的になるでしょう
そうして消費社会に閉じ込められて
命が喜ばない そういう人たちが
また量産されていく
生物の進化というのは 自らの生存を脅かす環境変化に
適応する形で成されてきました
消費 文明社会の先頭を走って
命が輝かなくなった我々日本は
もしかしたら 人類の進化の最先端に今
立っているのかもしれません
その進化とは 頭と体 都市と地方
もっと言えば 先進国と途上国の
均衡 バランスを図っていく
そういう壮大なチャレンジになっていくでしょう
70年代 パーソナルコンピューターが出てきましたね
情報が贅沢品だった時代です
あの頃 人々は高揚しました
その場にいながら世界中の情報にアクセスできる
そうしてあの大きな箱を持ち運びできるようにして
使いやすくしたのはスティーブ・ジョブズでした
その延長線上にこのiPhoneがあります
しかしもはやこの頭の世界 この箱の中の世界も
かなり開墾してしまってですね
もはや情報は贅沢品ではありません
むしろ この世界最先端の消費社会において
私たちの贅沢品は今 関係性と生存実感になっています
そしてこの関係性と生存実感 生きる実感は
決してマンションの一室にこもって
iPhoneで買えるものではありません
自然に出て そして生産者と共に
自らが生み出していくものなんです
そこが私は新しい 私たちの命が喜ぶ
フロンティアになっていくと思います
そしてそのフロンティアは
一人の天才が切り開くものではもはやありません
食べる人と作る人が一緒になって
開墾していくんです
その先に新しいふるさとが
待っているんではないでしょうか
このアップルは
私たちの頭と知識を豊かにしてくれました
それに対して私は こちらのアップル
リアルな食べ物
私たちの命を支えてくれる
このリアルな食べ物の世界につながることで
私たちの心を豊かに そして
私たちの命に輝きを取り戻していきたいんです
それを実現する為に
こっちのアップルも上手に活用していきたいと思います
つまり頭と体 都市と地方の融合です
皆さん 誰にとっても身近な
この 食べるということから
皆さんお一人お一人が
世界を変えられる力を持っていることを自覚してください
世なおしは 食なおし
さぁ皆さん
進化の最前線を楽しみながら
世界を変える冒険に出発しようではありませんか
終わります